in another video I talked about how most
organizations are designed so that
communication flows down the chain of
command and then less you are delivered
about this you're not going to get good
upward communication so we're gonna talk
about three ways that you can gather
high quality upward communication let's
unpack the details hello again friends
Alex Lyon here in this channel
communication coach is here to help you
increase your impact so you can lead all
the people around you to higher levels
of excellence and I believe that
communication and leadership are two
sides of the same coin if you want to
become a better leader you've got to
work at your communication especially
how to gather good upward communication
because gathering upward communication
is the key to making better decisions
you need good Intel if you want your
decisions to resonate with the people
who have to follow through on them one
of the big problems that I talk about in
my book however is that oftentimes when
communication gets passed up the chain
of command it gets distorted so at each
level the person passing information up
tends to leave off negative information
and emphasize anything that makes
themselves look good even if they don't
realize they're doing this what ends up
happening is by the time that message
gets to you the decision-maker it's
often way off and no longer represents
reality so what you want to do is
develop a process to make sure you get
high quality Intel or high quality upper
communication that's not distorted so
the three tips we're gonna talk about
today do that the first way to do this
is through a very simple survey and when
I'm talking about simple I'm saying like
one two maybe three or four questions a
survey that you put out on a specific
issue and the data the results go
directly to you they don't need a lot of
interpretation what ends up happening a
lot of times is academics or consultants
like me get involved in sometimes we ask
surveys that like 30 40 50 questions and
the results are overwhelming they need a
lot of interpretation there's too much
wiggle room for how you might understand
what you're looking at so if you ask a
really simple survey
you get those results and you can take
action on them immediately there are
many free services that you can use to
do this like Survey Monkey online if
your organization is big enough you
might already have data that's online on
something like glassdoor.com you could
take a look at that but those are two
simple ways that you can get a survey
out get information back really quickly
the second way is Skip level meetings
when you skip one or more levels of your
organization you're getting information
that's more pure so maybe you're meeting
with people one-to-one or maybe you have
a group of people meeting with you you
can ask them questions directly and draw
them out a little bit and then you're
going to get pure information that
hasn't been distorted at each level now
this takes little guts and it takes a
little getting used to but these skip
level meetings are an invaluable source
of high quality Intel you want to make
better decisions start skipping people
in the middle you're probably going to
get pushback from some of the middle
management folk who don't understand why
they're not involved but you have to
work on this it's really important to
your leadership and the Third Way is in
any time you're meeting with your people
one-to-one let's say you supervise six
or seven or maybe ten people directly
they report directly to you you want to
dedicate every so many meetings to
upward communication only so let's say
you're meeting with everybody
individually about once every couple of
weeks maybe every third meeting or every
fourth meeting dedicate that meeting
entirely to asking them questions draw
them out so you're mentoring them and
you're helping them on those other
meetings but every third or fourth
meeting hey how are things going what
needs to be changed around here how can
I be a better leader and like skip level
meetings this takes some guts but the
more you do it the more you get used to
it and the more those lines of
communication are open and you're more
likely to get higher quality Intel that
has not been distorted so all these ways
are just about free to do they don't
just take a little bit of time a little
bit of attention and a little bit of
creativity in terms of drawing this
information out but those are three ways
that you can establish dedicated
channels for upward communication
question of the day what are your
favorite ways to gather up word
communication I would love to hear your
comments and that
section below so thanks god bless and I
will see you in the next video